in the past people used to find tricks
and detours to make Google search engine
think that they should be ranked at the
top of the page but the algorithm just
became smarter than us and it
understands when people try to do evil
tricks like writing your top keywords in
white in the background of your page
just don't work anymore but nice try
that being said there's still things
that you can do to help your SEO your
best choice is to make sure your website
is relevant to the keywords that you're
trying to promote if your keyword is Pet
Sitting you really want to make sure
that people that are searching for Pet
Sitting will find your website useful
and will want to spend more time on your
website
that being said words matter the search
algorithm searches every single word on
the web including every word on your
page so the words you put on the page
matter however don't just pack your site
with search terms because the algorithm
is going to be able to tell if they're
actually relevant to your site or not
and if it's actually useful to the
person doing the searching so if it's
not the algorithm is going to end up
working against you you're going to want
to make sure that you refresh your
content so it's always up to date and
staying alive if you have quality
growing content on your site and growing
links to your site the better the search
engine algorithm is going to rate you on
that note what other people say matters
it's even better when other people say
the great things about your website that
you would like to say yourself for
example if on the first page of
TechCrunch they say that abarkment is
the best pet-sitting app with a link to
our site that makes us look really good
because they're validating that well
we're awesome so this will help our SEO
however don't forget that the algorithm
is smart if you try to just buy links to
your site that aren't actually relevant
the search engine is going to know the
more trustworthy your site is the higher
the algorithm rates you the title of
your page or the metadata on your page
also matter
now this isn't visible to users it's
actually hidden in your codebase but it
matters because it's used as a
suggestion
or the title and the Google search
results this is where you're going to
want to describe your business in an
informative and concise phrase this is
also true for your domain name it needs
to be easy to read and easy to
understand and finally don't leave your
images hanging people often forget to
optimize our images you're going to want
to give your images a short descriptive
file name and in the alt attribute
describe what the image is and don't
forget to add a caption for each image
your caption should also contain your
keywords